consider the curve given by the equation
y to the third minus XY is equal to two
it can be shown that the derivative of Y
with respect to X is equal to Y over 3 y
squared minus X all right write an
equation for the line tangent to the
curve at the point negative 1 comma 1
all right so we can figure out the
equation for the line if we know the
slope of the line and we know a point
that it goes through so that should be
enough to figure out the equation of the
line so the line is going to have a form
Y is equal to MX plus B M is the slope
and is going to be equal to dy DX at
that point and we know that that's going
to be equal to let's see Y is when X is
negative 1 Y is 1 that sits on this
curve so Y is 1 so 1 over 3y squared so
3 times 1 squared which is 3 minus X
when y is 1 X is negative 1 or when X is
negative 1 Y is 1 so X is negative 1
here and so this is the same thing as 3
plus positive 1 and so this is equal to
1/4 and so the equation of our line is
going to be y is equal to 1/4 X plus B
now we need to solve for B and we know
that the point negative 1 comma 1 is on
the line so we can use that information
to solve for B this line is tangent to
the curve so it includes this point and
only that point that's what it has in
common with the curve and so Y is equal
to 1 when X is equal to negative 1 plus
B and so we have 1 is equal to negative
1/4 plus B you add 1/4 to both sides you
get B is equal to we could either write
it as 1 and 1/4 which is equal to 5/4
which is equal to 1.25 we could write it
any of those ways so the equation for
the line tangent to the curve at this
point is y is equal to our slope is 1/4
X
Plus and I could write it in any of
these ways I'll write it as plus five
over four and we're done at least with
that part of the problem